for many families talking about the
potential of gun violence in school is
never easy one valley family says while
it's hard it's also necessary to make
your children be alert
just starting the conversation is the
important part joy and phil hoover are
talking about gun violence with their
two young daughters both parents
agreeing dropping off their daughters at
school after hearing about the shooting
at the texas elementary school wasn't
easy their peace of mind knowing both
nine-year-old vivian and five-year-old
ruby are educated on what to do if an
emergency happens
a hard walk down where if that does
happen we like turn off all the lights
we lock all the doors vivian quickly
stepping in to comfort her sister as a
conversation they say can get
overwhelming do you feel
scared
yeah and overwhelmed overwhelmed yeah
sometimes those things happen
psychiatrist dr sid kirana with nevada
mental health says preparation helps
proactive dialogues with parents
teachers and the community are key if
the child is getting more and more
scared or upset by me talking it is time
for me to stop it's time for me to take
a break let them process and digest what
we have said and then let them come back
and be ready for the next round the
hoovers also say being involved in
community events helps their daughters
understand what's happening they say
being proactive works for them i don't
think there's a perfect answer i think
the answer is
what is going to work best for your
family but i think the answer is always
to say something